last time mitch white pitched here was
august 18th against the pirates he came
on in the second and in relief and
finished the game seven and a third
shutout
only two hits and he cut down on his
walks the fastball location much much
better the breaking ball he's got the
slider and the curve ball and he'll
throw the change up rarely to lefties
conor joe making him work here to open
the game the eighth pitch gets a swing
and a miss and a strikeout opens the
game opponents now one for 25 this year
against mitch white slider
and this is lied down the line that's a
fair ball into the right field corner
playing chase's billy mckinney brendan
rodgers is going to stop at third
so a blackman double
second and third one out here in the
first cj base hit his first time up last
night and then three fly balls to center
field
hammered deep left field way back
three run jack cj crone
and the beat goes on in the month of
august for the rockies first baseman
start your afternoon with a three-run
blast
told you that senzu's last four have
been good he's not won a road game this
year and a lot of that has to do with
lack of
run support as we were alluding to
aj pollock hits this ball well to right
really well charlie at the wall or a
couple steps in front makes the catch
so sensatella ground ball two fly balls
and the rockies take a three-nothing
lead to ending number two
got him to taste same way that he
finished him off the first time and he
scored a second for white
three nothing middle two
we had an injury with john gray last
night
and john this is a bun attempt by
bellinger sansa that's a great job
popping off the mound was not close at
first
so bellinger struggling enough that he
tried to chew out bunt
six in a row set down to begin the ball
game four pitch inning
yeah i mean it has different depth and i
think it's always important to have
different looks use ball was hammered to
deep left and it is over the head of
pollock
and dig it towards second and arriving
with a double is rogers well the first
one was a sharp breaker that one hung up
a little bit and rogers barreled it
paints a fast ball to ring him up
we talked about fastball location how he
worked so hard and his side works on the
location well this one works in any
count
got him three consecutive sliders to
eliminate chrome
two on two out 2-0 it is hit on the
ground right side seeger to his left
makes the play the sword is third for
mitch right
the bottom half we go
dodgers a giants match up one more time
that's it early september it's labor day
weekend and that's it and it's in san
francisco
good pitch by senzitelli strikes out
mckinney
not sure
this is a slow roller to short
story throws out mitch white
that was a rough inning for centella 11
pitches
there he goes
and no chance for barnes
even if barnes fires off a throw there
they have no real chance to get
hilliard he had a great jump at first
one four for white
to deliver the baseball that's not
enough time for barnes and even if
barnes
snaps it down the major league average
from
about a 13-foot lead to second base is
right around
3.4 seconds
got him swinging
robin would have liked that in a little
different location but he gets the swing
and a miss a big strikeout huawei
because of this
situation even though it's early the
game feels like kind of
hanging by a thread here
dave roberts going to go to bruce star
gradual
got him bottom falls out
big strikeout for grader all
a pop-up
on the infield assuming they can find it
in the big ball of fire
the ending is over
blue star gradual comes on he gets out
of the bases loaded jam it stays three
nothing
[Applause]
three two he got him dialed up 97 to
strike out muncie
second strikeout on the afternoon for
antonio senzatella kyle finnegan of
washington
this ball is lifted to right charlie
makes the catch another one two three
inning
four
pretty close to immaculate innings for
senzatella three-nothing rockies
seeger taylor and bellinger siegel with
the line drive base hit
the old kona jinx
[Music]
way to go kona
never appreciate it
you sense it can get double play ball
struck him out
came all the way back
and that's his third strike out of the
ball game
3-2 got him with a 96 mile an hour
tailing fastball
two gone
two two
ground ball right to short
well done antonio senzatela so he works
out of a situation and we march on to
the sixth the rockies lead the dodgers
three nothing in la
nunez's second two gone
rocky's up three nothing first pitch
from joe kelly is lifted to center field
bellinger on the move still going oh
[Applause]
why is he not in the lineup well this is
why he's in the lineup
looking serials in the morning
this is playable left side
rio ruiz
senzatella another one two three inning
to the seventh we go the rockies
shutting out the dodgers three nothing
at first
and this ball is lined to left field and
deep and that'll take a short hop off
the wall blackman to third
he'll stop there and trevor story snaps
the o for 22 with a line double to left
we'll find a way to take advantage here
here we go again 3-2
and this ball is lined to deep right
caught by betts trotting home with a
fourth run as charlie blackman
very good a b for rio ruiz finally got a
fastball and he squared it up
this goes to the backstop and the
rockies will get a fifth run
story cruises home
on a wild pitch
chris taylor fly ball to
deep left and a strikeout
fly ball left near the line and
yeah the catch is made
on the other side of the wall
by connor joe connor plenty of time to
get under this one and because the low
fence at dodger stadium you do have the
opportunity to reach over
and grab it
and again this time he went so
bellinger's out number two fifth
strikeout
for senzatella
this is popped up playable
krone
will make the catch what a job by
senzitella
okay so uh for the ninth inning justin
turner is going to pitch
[Music]
turner said you're making me nervous
stop
to left center pollock is there
and there's a new leader in dodger
franchise history era
0-0-0
his name is justin turner
[Applause]
on the ground to short trevor's got it
and the rockies have shut out the
dodgers five to nothing and they take
two of three in los angeles over the
weekend
you